let's talk about the five women's
products that should be avoided now
there are always alternatives everything
toxic out there and when we talk about
products there are still things on the
market
that are
very unsafe very toxic and you need to
be aware of them so let's start with
compact powder so we're talking about
talc powder or talcum powder and they
use that in all sorts of
women's products from creams to
finishing powders materials that are
used for eye shadow blushes foundations
and many beauty creams now talc is the
softest mineral and it's highly
absorbable so it'll absorb the oil from
your skin
and give you an appearance of kind of a
soft silky
texture at least at first now here's the
problem with talcum powder when they
mine it it always comes with something
else called asbestos and so up to 20
percent of all products out there with
talcum powder
have asbestos
as a contaminated ingredient and the
problem with asbestos is it can leave
you with a malignancy
called mesothelioma so if you're
currently using compact powder you want
to find a brand that is asbestos free
now there's two sites that i put in the
description that you can find a
non-toxic talcum powder all right number
two nail polish and now remover boy i
don't understand how some people that
work
in the environment of doing nails can
tolerate the toxicity
of these chemicals
and if you personally work in a place
like that you at least need to get
in an air ionizer to help reduce these
chemicals in the air but what's the big
deal with nail polish well it has
chemicals like tooling which is in
gasoline i mean it's a solvent it's in
there to keep the paint from separating
but if you breathe it in it can create a
central nervous system toxicity and it
kind of bad effects on your reproductive
organs they also put formaldehyde
in nail polish now what's wrong with
formaldehyde well it's a great
preservative if you're embalming someone
but you have to realize that the nail
is alive
and your body can absorb things through
the nail so whatever you put on the nail
gets absorbed then we have dibutyl
phalae so this ingredient adds some
flexibility to the paint and it prevents
it from cracking and turning brittle
however
it gets absorbed in your blood and it
can
negatively affect your reproductive
organs i mean it's considered an
endocrine disruptor then when you put
the paint on then eventually you have to
remove it with nail polish remover and
they use acetone for that now the
problem with acetone is it's on the
hazardous substance list
it has a clear colorless kind of a sweet
odor
and it's a solvent for oils fats waxes
resins
plastics i mean if you read this list
it's incredible it's like
can cause headaches nausea vomiting
dizziness lightheadedness and even
passing out it may affect the kidneys in
the liver
it's a flammable liquid and a dangerous
fire hazard oh yeah and then the first
aid section skin contact quickly remove
contaminated clothing immediately wash
contaminated skin with a large amount of
soap and water well guess what you're
putting this right on the surface of
your body i don't know do people think
that it doesn't get absorbed or because
it's on the nail and the nail supposedly
dead which is not
is somehow not going to affect them now
as far as a cancer hazard
acetone has not been tested for its
ability to cause cancer in animals so
even though they didn't test it doesn't
mean that it can't cause cancer so
anything that is a fire hazard should
not be put
on your body what i recommend is simply
find an eco-friendly
non-toxic
nail polish and nail remover they have
them and i'll put a link down below with
a few that i found all right number
three intimate wash
products they call these feminine
hygiene products which they have washes
and wipes and shaving gels and
lubricants and apparently a lot of women
buy these products but are they really
needed and what are they doing to the
microbiome that lives in the vaginal
canal the chemicals are killing the
microflora
and altering the ph
there is a much increased risk when you
use these products of developing
cervical cancer
utis
pelvic inflammatory disease
hpv
genital warts genital herpes but why
because you're destroying the immune
system those microbes are the defense
mechanism
and so if you don't have a defense
mechanism you're more susceptible to
getting
unfriendly pathogens the normal
lactobacillus that lives in the vaginal
canal
produces lactic acid which actually
really helps the ph become slightly
acidic and that acts as another barrier
so when the ph increases and becomes
more alkaline a woman becomes more
susceptible to having a lot of
problems and irritation and redness etc
so a very simple solution is to use a
probiotic for vaginal health okay
i don't have any brand names but you
definitely want to check that out and go
in that direction all right then we get
to number four
hair removal
creams and the chemical mostly used is
called
theoglycolic acid
now anytime you put
anything on your skin and then within
minutes later you can wipe off your hair
that should bring up a red flag because
what this acid does is it dissolves the
keratin
in your hair and guess what theo
glycolic acid is also on the hazardous
substance list it's a corrosive chemical
and contact can severely irritate and
burn your skin now as far as the cancer
hazard well they haven't tested it to
see if it causes cancer in animals so
the jury's still out but check this out
it says avoid skin contact yet you're
putting it on your skin and it even says
to wear protective gloves when you're
using this acid so if you don't like
hair on your body
don't use this chemical
you might want to just wax
all right and number five
permanent hair dyes there's over 5000
different chemicals that they use
in dyeing your hair
and unfortunately some are known
carcinogens they can cause cancer the
chemicals are going on your scalp which
has the ability to get absorbed and go
right into your bloodstream
and they can act on your endocrine
system they can affect your hormones
some chemicals are considered endocrine
disruptors and in one large study called
the sister study which was performed on
45 000 women they found there was an
increased risk of breast cancer and
bladder cancer so there are natural dyes
out there that you should use
but when you're dyeing your hair
always ask questions and look at the
ingredients of what's in this dye to
make sure they're they're just not
filled with a list of chemicals that you
can't even pronounce and because we're
on the topic of
chemicals and toxicity
the next best video for you to watch
would be the one on the liver check it
out right here